a dangerous round-the-world adventure
an epic race against six other yawns
battling the elements pushing themselves
to the limit
but this year an extra dimension got a
plastic bag around our tail gathering
data in a race against time
to help stop us killing our oceans the
village tells us the micro testing is
everywhere so we need to understand it
before I really started to cause harm we
are in the perfect
[Music]
[Music]
the Volvo Ocean Race
since 1973 this has been the ultimate
test for the world's best sailors
the scariest thing I've ever done leaves
another leaving Malthus to wallow face
[Music]
seven identical yachts whose cruise
travel across four oceans from Europe to
South Africa and then on to Australia
the circumnavigation will take eight
months and brings him to Asia and New
Zealand as well as parts of the globe
seldom visited by humans by the time
they reach Brazil the United States and
return to Europe they'll have travelled
around 45,000 nautical miles and called
at 12 ports but mankind's impact on our
planet has no boundaries so this year
it's not just about conquering the
oceans it's also about protecting them
one boat named turn the tide on plastic
has been sponsored by organizations
including sky ocean rescue which
campaigned for cleaner seas few people
know the state of our oceans better than
the sailors who travel across them
therefore UN Environment is very happy
to have partnered with the race to help
spread awareness about one of the most
pressing environmental issues of our
time
it's easy to see plastic when it washes
up on beaches roughly eight million tons
of plastic enters the oceans every year
but most of it is slowly disintegrating
into tiny particles known as micro
plastics out at sea and out of sight
the crew on turned the tide is unusual
it's an even mix of men and women most
are under 30 and relatively
inexperienced
but there's something else that sets
this boat apart it's collecting samples
which will provide the most
comprehensive data set yet on the micro
plastic that threatens marine life and
ultimately human health their skipper is
dica firey a former teacher and the only
woman to have sailed solo around the
world in both directions she was worried
about the extra challenge on top of the
sailing that was proposed to us this is
just a joke we're just being asked to be
distracted from the racing all the time
her right-hand woman is Liz Wardley she
spent most of her life living and
working on boats her vast experience
meant she took on the extra
responsibility of maintaining the
science equipment and all this science
science lingo going on a little bit more
filters her caution was understandable
there are times when weather conditions
means the workload on board is
relentless they operate for hours on
four hours off with little time for
sleep never mind extra duties
besides different densities and try and
get their tiny tiny pieces at the
beginning when we started building it I
thought it was gonna be real hassle I
didn't think it was gonna be very
reliable it was a prototype that had
never really been tested before and
they've been on a racing boat which
moves around quite a lot we were a
little bit worried about carrying 45
kilos of a science experiment but the
folks have been waited to amend for that
you're down there you've got the covers
opened got your filter out you've got
tiny little pincers to pull this filter
out and then you aiming these filters in
then of course your new filters can't
make contact with the floor or your
hands or anything plastic or and I just
go flying around but Liz and her crew
embraced the mission they say it gave
them a sense of purpose compared to
their rival boats and it wasn't long
before the boat encountered the kind of
plastic we're all too familiar with
we're moving amazed by Jesse a nice pink
polystyrene we've seen in the ocean in
the last hour
sleeping adults one of under my pond a
paradise here we are the thirties but
the basis
on one side of the boat paradise the
other side is our human waste that's
destroying the ocean
soon plastic even began to interfere
with their racing lastingly we got a
plastic bag around our cue
it's kind of ironic for us I guess this
was hanging over the side to make the
focus I was actually a plastic bag grab
the rubber so here we are in the middle
of the south of observation miles from
anywhere
it's a plastic bag
we were before the thousands of miles
away but united by a passion for sailing
and the sea is the man who will make
sense of the data what is it you love
about it if you know we probably by the
window it's quiet
dr. toaster Tamura once sails solo from
his home in Sweden all the way to
California he's now a chemical
oceanographer based in the German city
of Kiel you really can then appreciate
the job that Liz and her colleagues are
doing art and they are pushing it and
when I get that channel weather
condition I go down a bit down in the
Southern Ocean with force ten wins and
10 me the ways that you know you don't
want to make a mistake
[Music]
danger at sea has existed since man
first built boats but now the threat has
reversed the ocean is at risk from human
activity a largely invisible threat but
a real one Tosca's colleagues sir and
Goethe Coons to collect the filters at
the end of each leg of the race and
brings them back to Germany where the
two men analyzed the samples in the
laboratory I don't think anyone has ever
measured not in that area a laser
detects the microscopic particles which
cannot be seen with the naked eye and
measures how many were present in each
sampling location every time I get these
filters and every time I also get the
oceanographic data of the system itself
I feel like a small child on Christmas
Eve and assess the scientists they are
really rare so it's a great but their
enthusiasm is tempered by concern of the
findings which are even worse than they
feared we find very high concentration
so microplastics around the military
inand we did find a lot of plastic in
places like of South Africa for instance
where I truly wouldn't think that
because that is more influenced by by
southern ocean so where in the world has
been the biggest area of concern so far
I think the fact that we found
significant amount of particles far away
in the southern ocean is concerning it
really tells us the microplastic is
everywhere there's no escape from it I
think there is you'll be very
hard-pressed to find a place where you
find no micro plastic
a billion people rely on seafood as
their primary source of protein many
more of us eat it regularly unaware that
some of it could be contaminated the
microplastics issue is much more
insidious because we can't actually see
the problem and scientists have done
some calculations to show that if you're
eating seafood regularly you may be
swallowing several thousand particles of
plastic a year
things like mussels or oysters they
filter water to get their food and they
take particles out of them and those
particles can be absorbed by those
organisms or can still be within them
when they're harvested buyers and end up
back in our place and we actually don't
know the extent of the risk at the
moment but I think we can say with some
certainty that if we don't both
understand the problem understand the
scientific challenges there will come a
point whether it be so much plastic in
the ocean that we will be facing hazards
that could be endangering human life the
data from turn the tide will be much in
demand but gathering it is a hazardous
business crew member is aware of the
risks but accidents happen
alright so she's flying for support deck
with a attach to the sheath it was
attached to the cell that had just
literally whipped for one side of a to
the other I was just scared I was gonna
break my leg people came to my rescue
and we got me untangle pretty quick in
the open ocean no one can predict what
will happen and one sailor will never
return home
[Music]
the Southern Ocean is the most
treacherous the most dangerous the most
exhilarating part of any global voyage
[Music]
the deck washing people from SP your
hands are frozen your feet of frozen
down below is worth the mattress had a
puddle in it about that deep
[Laughter]
in these conditions one wrong move can
capsize the boat
[Music]
[Music]
one of the worst fears of a southern
nation is the Chinese jive
[Music]
you end up facing with everything on the
one side and the boat on its side
anybody down below has to really work
hard at getting out on debt
[Music]
the secret is to get going again without
losing any confidence otherwise you're
just too scared to put these cells back
up
[Music]
Legg seven of the Volvo Ocean Race takes
the fleet from Auckland New Zealand
around Cape Horn to itajaí in Brazil
more time spent in the hostile southern
ocean and when something goes wrong and
part of the rig breaks the crew have to
find a way of fixing it quickly or fall
further behind in the race liz is one of
the most experienced members of the crew
not someone the skipper can afford to be
without but another accident puts her
temporarily out of action
the risks the sailors face became
tragically real as the yachts approached
Cape Horn race headquarters sent the
fleet a devastating email we had about
35 knots winds freezing we're expecting
more wind big sea state and I saw on the
subject that overboard first reaction
was there's no coming back from this
it's like the guys lost rival yachts shk
scallywag was being battered by strong
winds and huge waves
just before dawn British crewman John
Fisher was knocked overboard by a
swinging mainsail despite a search he
was never found
[Music]
affected us all quite emotionally we
were very placed to scouting about
there's a team we've done a lot of
trading together everyone you're in
pretty well he was it was definitely one
of the biggest characters of the of the
race he was really really nice and was
one of our big supporters actually he
was always the first one down on the
dock to meet us in and sort of
encourages along and he'd stop us all in
their race village and have a chat and
he was very supportive going
[Music]
it was a painful reminder of the danger
they faced while racing and at the same
time carrying out the research the crew
of the scientists stay in regular
contact thanks to the most up-to-date
satellite communications something going
it's an opportunity to provide updates
on the results we do find comparable
concentration on microplastic even in
the South Pacific as we did in the South
Indian Ocean going up to Melbourne so we
seen that we have plastic everywhere so
far even in the region of point Nemo the
remotest place on the planet nearly
1,700 miles from inhabited land and yet
26 particles of plastic per cubic meter
of seawater were measured when sailing
here you can be closer to the crew of
the International Space Station than
anyone on earth the highest readings
were recorded close to big population
centers including in the western
Mediterranean at the beginning of the
race 307 particles there and in the
South China Sea close to Hong Kong where
they found 349 particles it's further
proof that micro plastic has become
pervasive and there's increasing concern
that these tiny particles pose a threat
to human health
the Portuguese Mir Puri foundation is
one of the sponsors have turned the tide
on plastic
it's medical advisor is deeply concerned
about the effects of the chemicals in
plastic could have it will be
catastrophic not now but in the third
generation each time well we have this
disease new diseases from new
contaminants we are having more cancer
more allergic diseases more infertility
we are less fertile than our
grandfathers are you saying the plastic
is killing the human race yes is killing
human race but slowly we don't realize
how many chemicals we have in the world
that could interfere with us the only
nerve system is like a symphony and it's
like when you traduced this is like
playing Chopin with a hammer
so they disrupt they they interfere with
Armand you just scare migrate or change
the way you use plastic and this is so
convenient for modern life we are not
gonna change if you are not scary
it's because of this concern that the
data collected during this race is so
important and all seven yachts
contribute to oceanic research drifter
boys will feed data about weather and
currents to satellites
he weighs 20 kilos and we're about to
deploy him into the southern ocean it's
water activated which is wires wrapped
in plastic so a necessary evil so we're
going to take this plastic off and then
we're ceremoniously gonna chuck him into
the ocean
but there's another more basic reason
why even this crew cannot avoid using
plastic believe it or not is toilet
paper and kitchen paper how do you keep
that dry in a yacht that's very damp and
humid all the time as a result we vacuum
pack our paper so that we can ensure
we've always don't want eyelet roll this
is single use plastic that we'd rather
not use but by nature of where we'll
operate it it's immediate
[Music]
the end of the eighth stage of the race
brings the yacht's to America along with
the next batch of filters which the
scientists are desperate to get their
hands on that's because there's still so
much we just don't know and until you
know the full extent of a problem it's
impossible to deal with it
scientists still don't know where 99% of
the plastic in the ocean actually ends
up until they do it's impossible for
selection the scientist and the Sailor
meet to discuss the latest data have the
highest numbers with 57 on that leg
that's really crazy because why wouldn't
you're signing along you don't see any
rubbish no it looks like clean
each host city stopover gives a chance
for the crews to rest for repairs to be
carried out to reflect on the race so
far and to publicize their mission
that's how they prefer to measure their
success because in pure racing results
turn the tide has consistently trailed
the leading boats although the actual
end result doesn't look that good the
racing that we've done has been pretty
good
my guys have done better than everyone
thought they would do and on top of that
we're actually contributing to data and
research and analysis of the issue of
microplastics
whilst communicating on the greater
scale of single-use plastics I'm proud
to be part of it it gives you a great
sense of achievement and especially when
we get the results back I'm standing by
the results but at the same time as
because of us that they have them and
that's that's great achievement this
year's event may be ending but another
kind of race is just beginning and those
involved are glad to see that a start
has finally been made we are able to
trace our knowledge that might help to
mitigate the problem or at least
understand the magnitude of the problem
so we can create solutions this was not
on anybody's agenda and not taken
seriously and now we're reaching the
point where in the same way having
smoking a cigarette in the public places
and a good thing it's now not so good to
be carrying a disposable coffee cup as
it was two or three years ago in future
races more yachts are likely to carry
the equipment to gather even more data
on microplastics the vast oceans cannot
be cleaned like a beach or a riverbank
the only solution to stop the pollution
at source
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]